italian fans here in the center of room
celebrating this victory the first time
italy has won
the european cup since 1968.
italy has posted 34 straight matches
undefeated it's an incredible run
especially considering
that they weren't even able to qualify
for the 2018 world cup
finals people here have been following
this team in this tournament
in a way that shows it's about much more
than football italy was
the first western country to be so hard
hit by the pandemic
and once this tournament got underway
you could see how italians
and other supporters from other
countries rallied around the team
because it was it was an outlet to show
their joy
coming back together now that the worst
days it seems of the pandemic
is behind italy so they were coming out
here to plazas to watch on screens like
this
to share in this unbridled joy and
they'll be watching to see
what steps come next for this team under
the leadership
of coach roberto mancini and what it
might mean
for the next world cup
you